Doogie Howser went to DC it's true
Mark Zuckerberg went to the Capitol
where he met creatures creatures old
enough to ride woolly mammoths on the
frozen tundra of Siberia
this wasn't a hearing it was a hard of
hearing it was tough watching Zuck
explain how the internet works to people
who mistake ipads for cutting boards but
how they pronounced chocolate i love a
certain kind of chocolate chocolate
chocolate I like chocolate he does I'm
scared of him this strange meeting
between two different worlds kind of
reminds me of a movie he came from
somewhere far away our planet had never
seen anything like him seeking
friendship he spoke a language that
befuddled our greatest leaders I would
differentiate between ISPs so there
might be areas where there needs to be
more regulation and one and less than
the other and to confuse them forcing
them to ask ridiculous questions who's
gonna protect us on Facebook does
Twitter the same as which even can you
define Bates
Facebook the financial institution what
was Facemash and if it's still up and
running he answered them in a language
only he and his fellow aliens understood
I will have my team follow up with you
have my team follow up my team my team
my team my team this sprint
witnessed the incredible story of a
being from another galaxy being probed
and tortured by human stupidity nuke man
when a unicorn Chaplin flamethrowers
while filing his taxes presents Mark
Zuckerberg Lindsey Graham and Carl
Weathers as dill m-z the Mark Zuckerberg
I felt bad for the guy because no one
got him but it's not really about age
it's about knowledge which this crowd
lacked if that hearing was not an
argument against regulation and for term
limits in small government I don't know
what is and if Zuckerberg is 10% the
genius that we think he is he better
have left that meeting of full-on
libertarian anyway deducted okay he wore
a suit finally I'm so proud of him I
think it's his first is your nephew
graduating from high school younger
sister having her first communion or
maybe you're going to Nana's funeral
then you need the SUP it's the first
suit for guys who've never worn a suit
before designed specifically to make you
look like a big boy on your big day like
that first day at work
hey guys
for that all-important first fancy date
it's a chilly night out you want my
jacket or even your first court
appearance I think you need to plead
guilty it was guys wearing back and go
to jail
suck and suck looks great at widely
covered congressional testimonies Porter
nail would throw in a free booster seat
buzz up your mom will hate the way you
look
we guarantee
[Applause]
Jamie yeah I we like me did you feel bad
for Zuckerberg being questioned for 10
hours I loved every minute of this yes
so he spent 10 hours listening to
opinions he didn't want to hear being
asked questions he didn't want to hear
posed hey that's what it's like to go on
Facebook happens every time I go on so
I'm glad he got to experience it should
there be any Content regulations um I
think there should be at some point
they'll have to do that if I could pick
one I would like there to be every time
I go on Facebook afterwards I feel bad
about myself mm-hmm for some reason I
read like all the everyone's doing all
these things I think you should have to
put some negative things on Facebook
whenever people pose like oh I did this
I did this you you never see someone
post something like I just gained 20
pounds I ate a pie every day for the
last 30 days I'm depressed and then it's
a picture of them holding up a small
pair of pants they used to fit into okay
you do that you go on no social networks
and you you're not always happy I like
to keep it honest you do you do do you
how fast you did that suit that he wore
end up in a pile in a laundry basket
never to be touched again immediately
yes he do not do very well I've seen
pieces of toast with more charisma and
they didn't even have butter on them I
got the vibe like he seemed like he was
a teenager being forced to volunteer in
a nursing home
that was kind of a bug that's really
what I thought but I just love how they
have such a little idea of what Facebook
really is but they do know that they
want to regulate exactly if that isn't
the government in a nutshell and I don't
know what yeah we are in we can't
explain it though I can order chocolate
I can order chocolate and then there's
it there's an ad for the chocolate so
how does this machine know that I like
the chocolate
Pyrus what are you making I have a
question for you Greg
yes yes yes I couldn't help but notice
your little commercial there those suits
those because those look a lot like my
jacket I didn't steal him from Brian
Kilmeade no so I got a Facebook post for
the guy who was wearing my suit yeah got
ass kicked today for wearing a big suit
you know that's the whole thing my
favorite cruise was my favorite part yes
because he wanted to ask a question and
he kept trying to go all he want to know
is any of his photos were out there he
wanted to go he wanted to know if he had
seen any of his stuff he's like so is
there any photos of guys from Texas who
might be a Republican who ran for
president and lost miserably no he
literally was just all he wanted to make
sure was none of his stuff was out there
that's it so you know everyone's dad
that's out there really well you know at
a certain point everybody's stuff is
gonna be out there we have to assume
privacy I believe Jedidiah is dead
everything is dead civility and all the
other good yeah the only things are
alive or really scary you um do you
think that we social media training
should be like given to everybody in the
Senate in Congress I watch this and I
was I can't believe we elected these
guys yeah I mean when you like we do
we're doing a basic television show now
if I got a list of topics and I looked
at one of them and I had no idea I would
read the link they're not embarrassed at
all to go sit there I mean we elect them
this is their job yes posted to the
research they're supposed to ask and you
know insightful questions they have no
[Applause]
all right hatch was the only person who
knew what was going on when he asked
like he basically said okay so it's free
how do they make money and then it's
like ever goes advertising and he was
basically saying to the people there
you're a bunch of idiot which they
didn't get they didn't get it they
thought he was being stupid but then you
know he said like that's how they make
money advertising and then you have
Charles Grassley who's like weeding
word-for-word something like an
assistant gave him from Wikipedia so
you're telling me Facebook isn't
actually a book of human faces speaking
of a book of human faces this book is
coming out soon you can order at Amazon
it's all of my monologues from the five
not all of them because it would look
would be really big the best this is
like 250 monologues and I add new stuff
in it I write about like stuff I got
wrong which is rare and add to the stuff
that I got right which is great it's
been endorsed by this little guy
[Applause]